So once this scripting data has been loaded, we can now move forward with our
assets, images, maps, etc. Now typically you can load assets and scripts at the
same time, but I've been burned by that in HTML once or twice. Injected
JavaScript code can easily suggest more assets to be loaded, which would
require more kickoffs of async calls and tracks that follow. As such for
sanity, well, mainly my receding hairline, we let Grids' scripting code come in
first, define their systems and asset needs and then kick off all the
subsequent asset loads afterwards. In Grids instead of calling Windows Alert
this is where we actually kick off phase three where we parse our texture
packer outlets definition and load the map objects. Once that was done, we can
actually let the user play the game by turning off the UI and showing the
canvas elements. Once we've gone through our three phases of loading the menu,
descripting data and then the assets, finally we can allow the user to get to
the screen and play the game. It's only through the combination of all of these
together do we ensure a nice easy transition for the user that constantly shows
them a refreshing UI.